[Music]
we're going to be investigating uh
different kinds of experimentation and
the limits of it
with three fabulous speakers john
yanedes is a professor of medicine of
health research
and of biomedical data science at
stanford university
and his 2005 paper why most published
research findings
are false brackets except this one is
the most downloaded paper of all time in
the public
library of science claudia de van
is an award-winning professor of
theoretical physics at imperial college
london
and claudia is recognized for her
revitalization of research into
massive gravity theory and harry collins
is one of the leading sociologists of
science in the world and teaches
at the school of social sciences cardiff
university
most recently he's been a prominent
voice on the role of experts in society
the importance of science in democracies
and the dangers of artificial
intelligence
so we're going to kick off as we do uh
at the festival with uh three uh brief
pictures we're gonna give
three minutes to each of our speakers to
answer uh a
simple question has human bias
broken the scientific
model and we're going to allow harry to
go first harry
what's your three-minute take well
my answer is no um
for the simple reason that the
scientific model
uh never really held up i think
there is a sort of subset of people who
think that science
is uh an automatic procedure it's
something you
can do by formula and uh when utopia
comes
science can be will be able to be done
by computers
working away automatically just
following
what karl popper called the logic of
scientific discovery
but actually science has never been like
that scientists have always disagreed
with each other scientists have always
looked at the same data and come up with
different results and so that any
formula
uh of that sort just doesn't hold up and
this even applies to the replicability
of experiments
i mean people think that you can test
a theory by replicating it but that's
only the case
when nobody's disputing it very strongly
if people are disputing it very strongly
and somebody says well i tried your
experiment
and it didn't work they'll say well
that's because you didn't do the
experiment properly
and if you go back to your time or to
your time at school you'll know that
most of the experiments you did never
worked in the first place anyway
until the teacher told you exactly how
to do it and scientists on the
frontier are in the same sort of
position really so that there never was
an experimental replication as a sure
way
to find out what's true or not it's
still sensible to
go for replications but it doesn't
produce an automatic answer
very good well that's admirably brief
and thank you claudia your three minutes
has human bias broken the scientific
model
i think we're humans of course we have
biases and that has affected
the way we do science it affects the way
we interact
with our environment and it affects the
way we relate to our observations and
make conclusions
but i think the way biases are taken
into account
scientific models can be very viable and
so it's not a scientific model as a
whole
maybe let me just give you an example
and for that let me talk about p-value
which is sometimes used as an indicator
to determining how likely
a result is just a an observation is
just the result
of a statistical fluke so just a random
noise if you will
in some fields there's a lot of
publications which are accepted in
journals
for which they have a p-value of .05
that means that there's one in 20
chances that
this result is just noise there's
absolutely no scientific content
in that results that's just the way it
is
would you jump on a plane if you knew
that it had one in 20 chances of falling
down
that's up to you to decide if you want
to compare this with other fields
let me just talk about the discovery of
the higgs particle for instance that's a
experiment that took over 49 years
uh to get accomplished it involved
thousands of scientists throughout the
planet
working together disagreeing sometimes
and ultimately
agreeing but they had blind analysis
throughout they had two independent
detectors
working in parallel and the announcement
was only ever made when it reached a
p-value of point let me zero see
zero zero zero zero three
so that corresponds to one chance in 3.5
millions
that it was just statistical noise it's
completely different
that's about the same probability as
going on a plane and the plane falling
down
so when you jump on a plane are you
biased towards thinking that it's safe
yes you are i am biased and i still go
on it
doesn't mean that the whole machinery is
broken and i should never do that again
that's up to you to decide
i mean this is all subjective
but thank you for that and john uh your
initial foray
into the territory has human bias broken
the scientific model
i think that science is the best thing
that has happened to humans
this sounds like good news but at the
same time it means that science is human
and we humans we are agents of errors
mistakes biases fallacies
you know we can very easily get it wrong
we can have strong beliefs we can have
strong interpretations we can have
strong priors some of them
justified others not justified
and this means that we have a constant
struggle between
some objective data and results
that may also be error prone and
they have their own noise and uh and
biases of all sorts
and also uh our interpretation and our
filtering
and our selective reporting and
selective cherry picking
of of that universe of accumulated
evidence
and and information this has been
the same since the very beginning of of
science you know it's it's a constant
struggle
at any point in time if you just take
the uh hundreds thousands millions
tens of millions of of papers that are
floating around
uh some of them will have far more
reliable
information uh compared to others and
some of them may even be useful
but very few of them actually will be
used but
it's going to be a continuum of
information that is very reliable all
the way to completely unreliable
information that is useful all the way
to being completely useless or even
harmful
so the the question is uh not to lament
about the lack of perfection or or the
fact that we have
humanity our human nature deal with with
these problems but just to try to do our
best
and i think that we have ways that we
can optimize the efficiency we can
optimize
the chances that what we will get
will be more reliable and eventually
also more useful
incentives and we're going to we'll come
back to those practical uh
maybe even useful uh uh tips a little
later
harry can i look back to you on on where
we began this little journey
can you imagine a truly objective
science
is that even something which it's worth
trying to bring to mind
or or is it is the enterprise fatally
flawed
from the outset well i mean i can
imagine
it i mean but i can imagine it being
described by a science fiction writer
um and it would you know what would that
world what would that world be like
i i should imagine i i can imagine isaac
asimov writing this
story about it you know and it would the
science would be done by computers
right so would there be humans in the
story i guess is the key question right
well would there be humans in the story
well yeah i can imagine it because i
think there are
sub domains within science where
you can approximate to
the model um claudia has
has been kind of intimating that high
energy physics
might be one of those subdomains but i
don't think she's right because uh
i mean high energy physics is very
interesting
because high energy physics has changed
its standards
for what counts as a discovery in the
1960s
it was through standard deviations and
as she says
nowadays it's five standard deviations
and
uh i'll tell you how
high if i can read out a quote how it
was that high energy physics
got from one place to another this is
from jay marx who was the
uh one time the director of the ligo the
ligo
which discovered gravitational waves he
says years ago difficult experiments
were done to study the weak interaction
some of those experiments were published
with high significance
three sigma and greater later turned out
to be wrong
while experiments had a five sigma
effect mostly turned out to be right
the result was a common wisdom or
mythology that one should not be
confident in a result
unless it was a five sigma effect and i
could continue like that so
physics has done a kind of big huge
long experiment on what level of
significance you need
if that's what you're relying on level
of significance
and physics is discovered you need at
least five
because physics still goes wrong because
there are some five sigma results that
turn out not to be right
such as the discovery of cosmic
gravitational
radiation which happened just before the
real gravitational radiation
so i mean claudia
you know the good bit of ad hominem
you're you're standing here
for physics uh and harry is trying to
persuade us
that while you might claim uh to believe
that
it's a truly objective science uh he's
he's chipping away at that
are you prepared to to return to your
defense of it do you think
that the the p-value arguments uh
do still make high-energy physics as
it's conducted today
a good candidate for a truly objective
science to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas